this is a photograph of debany escobar
it was taken on the night she
disappeared in monterrey mexico exactly
one month ago
though multiple government agencies
participated in the search for debane
her lifeless body was found almost two
weeks later at a location that had been
overlooked as many as four times by
searchers as public pressure mounted on
state prosecutors authorities were
forced to admit some mistakes may have
been made in the handling of the
investigation
we will focus all the resources at our
disposal towards determining what
happened and if this implies a crime has
taken place we will apply the full force
of the law
debane's family says the case highlights
the failures of authorities both to
protect women in mexico and to solve
crimes committed against them
debony was missing for several days the
state prosecutor's office didn't do
their job correctly my mistake was
trusting the prosecutor's office
disappearances are an all too common
problem in nuevo leon in just the first
few months of this year more than 60
women have been reported missing in the
city of monterrey alone
gerardo martinez has been looking for
his sister for more than a month now he
says assistance from the government in
finding her has been like having no help
at all
for me the first 16 days she was missing
were wasted which is very important the
longer my system remains missing is
evident the authorities are not doing a
good job
many in this part of mexico say that a
lot of the complaints about the
government lacking resources having poor
training and a tendency by authorities
to downplay the seriousness of the
problem can be traced back decades
juana solis daughter brenda went missing
in 2011. though brenda was later found
dead juana has since dedicated her time
to helping other families find their
missing loved ones alive and to call on
the government to do more about missing
persons cases
ms it's the same investigators as always
and the same inconsistencies as 2011 the
authorities don't do their jobs right
they say they have equipment but we
looked into this and the only thing new
is their job titles
[Applause]
the case of debonai escobar sparked
protests across mexico once again
shining a spotlight on the worsening
problem of impunity which experts say
fuels higher rates of violence and
disappearances
according to the latest report by the
united nations committee on enforced
disappearances
748 women disappeared in mexico in just
the first four months of this year
that's an average of seven women going
missing every day manuel rapalo al
jazeera mexico city